ROMAN NURIK: Let's
start that again.
And for those of you watching
live, pardon the interruption.
And for those of you that are
watching on YouTube after,
during the recording, we
had a little kerfuffle.
And it is now fixed.
So anyway, thanks for joining
Android Design in Action.
Once again, I'm your host,
Roman Nurik, joining from
Chelsea Market, our wonderful
new little recording studio
here in New York City.
I'm joined today by
Nick Butcher.
NICK BUTCHER: Hello,
from London.
ROMAN NURIK: Hailing all
the way from London.
And today we're going to talk
about football apps.
And you know, the Super
Bowl just happened.
So everybody's probably
thinking
American football apps.
No, we're going to be talking
about the other kind of
football, soccer or European
football, if you call it
something else.
NICK BUTCHER: Or if you're
anywhere in the rest of the
world other than America,
just football.
ROMAN NURIK: Right.
Well, the Australians apparently
call it something
else, right?
Oh, they call it
soccer as well.
I don't know.
Never mind.
So we're going to talk about
football tracking apps.
But we're really going to
talk about one app.
We're going to look at an app
called Live Score Addicts.
NICK BUTCHER: Maybe
we should--
just to interject
a little bit--
I think, change from our regular
format, where we
normally work with the app
clinic, so the App Clinic will
take a look at a bunch
of applications
within a given topic.
And then we'll turn our
attention to why and try and
re-envisage how it might look
with the application of the
Android design principles.
We're mixing it up a
little bit here.
And we're actually going
to go first.
We're looking at one application
which has come
from the suggested topic
from the App Clinic.
And then those guys are going
to take it from us and run
with some of our suggestions,
and go a little bit deeper
into some of the implementation
steps for the
more developer crowd
out there.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
Good catch, Nick.
So it is kind of a new format.
If you're looking to nominate
your app to be reviewed at
some point on the App Clinic and
Android Design in Action,
please still keep using the
Trello board for now.
We're going to keep sourcing
stuff from there.
And also, if it is a
self-nomination, if you're
nominating your own app, please
make sure to state
that, because we want to make
sure that folks that are
nominating their own
app get precedence.
So with that, we're also going
to talk about launcher icons,
specifically the icons that
represent your application in
both the Play store on under
the Google Play client, as
well as on the web, as
well as on the device
once you install it.
So with that, let's
get started.
Wow, this tablet keeps
shutting off.
So like I said, we're going to
talk about football apps, and
specifically Live
Score Addicts.
So let's get started.
Nick, do you want to introduce
Live Score Addicts?
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
So for anyone who is a football
or soccer fan, this
is one of those applications
which lets you keep on top of
fixtures and results,
essentially.
It's quite a focused
application.
It doesn't do the whole
gamut of news and
everything around that.
It's very much about keeping
track of what's just happened
or what's coming up, as well
as having quite a strong
during the game focus as well.
So you might want to have this
application open, be receiving
notifications, and see what's
going on with the other teams
playing at the same time.
And it's worth noting, actually,
the developers have
just put out a re-design.
And I hear it's a great
improvement on the previous
look and feel of the
application.
And I think they've done
a pretty decent job.
But we've kind of done a little
deep-diving on some of
the fit and finish and polish
aspects of the application to
really make it shine, we feel.
ROMAN NURIK: And just to
reiterate, any time we look at
an app and we provide
re-designs, we're not saying
that the app is currently
designed poorly or
anything like that.
We're just exploring other ways
in which to present that
information.
We do sometimes look at apps
that are worse, I guess,
generally worse from an
aesthetic and UI standpoint.
But we definitely don't mean to
say your app sucks, here's
a better version.
It's purely just here are some
thoughts that they can use to
improve the app.
This is the first screen that
we're going to take a look at.
We're going to take a look at
about three or four screens.
This is basically the
onboarding process.
And it's kind of a wizard, where
it takes you through the
different leagues, and lets
you customize what are the
things you want to see
in the app, what are
you interested in?
I'm guessing if you're a
football fan, you're not
interested in every single
league out there, because
there are millions.
Even just within the UK, there
are probably hundreds or
thousands or something.
So you can really customize what
specific leagues you're
interested in.
And then in the later steps, you
actually get to customize
the notifications, which things
you want to be notified
of in the status bar.
So we took a look
at this screen.
And we thought, how can
we make it feel
a little more Androidy?
And so we came up with a version
that's using a more
common wizard-like UI.
And I posted some sample code
for this a few months ago.
It was called wizard pager.
So this is using some hints
from that wizard pager,
including things like
having a bottom bar
for Next and Previous.
It's worth noting here that
some folks think, there's
already a back button on the
device, why wouldn't
you just use that?
Well, I actually had a talk
with our design team, our
Android User Experience team,
and they felt that, in this
case, this is actually one of
those really weird edge cases
where you don't actually want to
overload the back button to
go back in the wizard, since
you have a very apparent
onscreen next affordance.
So Previous and Next at the
bottom, very similar to an OK,
Cancel presentation
in dialogues.
And then for indicating which
step you're looking at,
there's this little strip at the
top that indicates you're
past step one, and now you're
looking at step two.
And step two is highlighted
in green, which is
your current step.
Additionally, we bumped up
the size of the imagery.
And again, in general, we love
to make image concept larger,
because it's a little
more engaging.
And so we made the country
logo a little larger.
We made the text a
little larger.
And then we also used more
hollow style elements for the
check boxes and things
like that.
So some very basic stuff.
But overall, we kind of tweaked
the screen to more
prominently highlight
the content.
Actually we had added an action
bar at the top that's
using a different palette, an
inverted palette, so that it
fades away and feels more like
the part of the system,
Chrome, the system UI, rather
than part of the application
in this case, and a couple
things like that.
Before we move on, Nick, is
there anything you wanted to
add to wizards or
onboarding flow?
NICK BUTCHER: No, I just think
while it might seem like
there's very small changes in
the screen, for me it really
works, because the use of more
standard controls really makes
it a lot easier to appreciate
what's going on on this page.
And that's very important when
you're talking about the very
first thing the user's going
to see when they first run
this application.
You've got this small window of
time to convinced the user
that your application's easy to
use, and they want to keep
it, and it's going
to be useful.
So I think the little bits
like using the standard
controls and making it
immediately obvious and easy
to pass the screen, as it were,
and understand what it's
offering you, really,
really help here.
Better than this might
even be to offer some
kind of sensible defaults.
So you might want to detect
which country they're in and
help them into some sensible
defaults, and then allow the
user to go through this
customization flow at a later
point, because it really is this
very, very crucial time,
the first time a user
runs an app.
So the visual changes here
for me are really great.
I mean, the bar at the top on
the original, showing which
step you're currently on, didn't
really speak to me.
It's a quite low contrast.
You're in the current step, and
there's repeated icons.
ROMAN NURIK: Right, there's just
a little white sliver.
And it's white on a tan
background, so the contrast is
very poor there.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, and having
to move your thumb all the way
to the top corner to
hit Next and so on.
So I think the small changes
that we've made really, really
make this screen much easier
to understand and to use.
ROMAN NURIK: And one other thing
I wanted to mention is,
in general, we actually have
a very good document in the
design guide that talks about
help as well as tutorials.
So in general, the guidance
there is actually if a user
doesn't need to make a decision
immediately, if you
can just stick with a default,
and that's OK for 60%, 70% of
people, let them skip
the tutorial.
You don't want to force them
to go through something.
In this case, you could argue
that the user has to choose
what they're interested in,
because otherwise you won't be
able to present them any
sort of useful data.
But as soon as you're done, as
soon as you're done specifying
the one thing you're
interested in,
let the user skip.
So find some way to
provide a skip or
get started now function.
So let's move on to the next
screen which we looked at,
which was the list of matches.
And so on the left here, you
see the list of matches.
And you'll notice that there's
actually a number of different
ways you can sort this.
You can sort this
by the league.
You can sort is by time, and a
number of different things.
We'll show this on the next
screen, but there's also the
navigation drawer on the left.
And we'll talk about
that in a bit.
There is also this button here
that filters by only live now
matches, so only matches that
are currently live.
And then you can swipe left and
right between yesterday
and tomorrow, as
well as today.
The issue I found with this is
that there's not actually a
yesterday minus 1 and a
yesterday minus 2 and so on.
You can only see those
three days.
It may be because of some sort
of policy thing, or maybe they
just don't have the data.
But in that case, do you
really need a set of
scrollable tabs?
So what we decided to do here
was we kind of re-imagined
what it would look like with
just tabs in a slightly
different color scheme.
We actually tweaked the color
scheme from a very deep
orangey brown to a slightly
more subdued brown.
And then we used, I call it a
turf green, as the highlight,
as the single accent that's
used throughout.
So this darkish desaturated
brown combined with the green
gives it a more earthy,
a little more
simpler feel, I'd say.
And then we also switched over
to the fixed tabs to show
yesterday, today,
and tomorrow.
And again, you should
still be able to
swipe between the three.
We also removed the navigation
drawer and switched to an
action bar spinner.
And I'll talk about that
on the next slide.
And then we used a slightly
different presentation for the
actual content, the actual
matches themselves.
We slightly made the
live matches a
little bit more prominent.
In that left column here, you'll
see that live matches
are kind of highlighted
in green.
And then any time you have set
up notifications for an
individual match, if you decided
that I really want to
follow what happens in this
match, you see a little green
tick at the very top right.
And it's not interactive.
It's probably worth mentioning
that if you wanted to make
this interactive, have a
notification button right in
line with the list item, this
should look very different.
But this is a very clear
signal that it's not
interactive, it's purely
an indicator.
Again, we bumped up the country
flags a little bit,
just to make that pop a little
more, since that's probably
something that's going to get
your attention fairly quickly.
And we used Roboto Light here,
as well as a Roboto Bold
Condensed to show the actual
current scores.
So I know that was a whammy.
Is there anything else you
wanted to mention, Nick, on
the screen?
NICK BUTCHER: It's got some
room to breathe now.
I think that the last screen,
the before version, as it
were, tried to stuff a lot of
content into the screen.
And in doing so, made it
less [? plausible. ?]
I find it quite hard to find
the individual event I'm
looking for.
So in the re-imagining, I really
like the way that you
used space and color and
contrast to really give a
hierarchy to the information,
so it's really easy to find
the section you're looking
for, then the game you're
looking for, or things that
are important, like a goal
that's just scored, or a game
that's on now really jump out.
So I think the information
hierarchy is really what
stings here for me.
ROMAN NURIK: And I think one of
the biggest contrasts here
is the information density.
You'll see on the left in
the current screen, the
information density
is very high.
You can see a lot of matches
all at once.
But I mean, my guess is, in
general, if you're a fan
following just a few games that
are happening now, you
probably don't really care about
all that information.
You probably do you care about
the two or three current
games, as well as maybe
a specific league
that has games today.
So don't be afraid of letting
your content breathe by
increasing margins, increasing
spacing, and slightly lowering
information density.
It'll make things a little more
readable, as well as make
your content a little more
consumable, and just overall
improve the aesthetic
in general.
So let's move on to the
next screen which I
wanted to talk about.
And this is the navigation
drawer versus
the action bar spinner.
So the navigation drawer here
provides you access to things
like matches, competitions, and
teams, which are the three
top level structural elements,
as well as settings and more.
And this is something that we
pointed out in the last
episode in the Hangout.
Things like Settings or Help
or About, or even just more
stuff, they generally don't
belong immediately on screen
or in the primary
navigation area.
And we've specifically outlined
that things like
Settings, Help, About, Terms
of Service, Privacy Policy,
those should really belong in
the action bar overflow.
So when you press this action
bar overflow here in the
action bar, you should see
things like Settings
and Help and About.
So we would probably move things
like that to there.
So if you remove Settings and
More, you're just left with
three items.
And with only three items
to choose from, three
navigational components, the
navigation drawer becomes a
little bare.
And so what you could do instead
is you could either
use tabs or an action
bar spinner.
In this case, we're already
using tabs to switch between
yesterday, today,
and tomorrow.
And so we decided to switch to
the action bar spinner as the
top level core structural
navigational component.
And so there you can switch
between matches,
competitions, and teams.
And it makes clear the three
main sections of the app.
So let's move on to the next
screen that we looked at,
which was the match
detail screen.
And in the match detail
screen, we
looked at a couple things.
Specifically, we looked
at the Statistics tab.
We also looked at just the
presentation of the current
game state.
So on the left you'll notice
that you have the position
title strip, or the scrollable
tabs at the top and then the
content at the bottom.
And then somewhere in the middle
is actually a fixed
pane, or I guess a fixed UI
element, that indicates the
current state of the game.
And so as you're swiping left
and right on the content or on
the top scrollable tabs, the
middle part stays fixed.
But the top and bottom actually
slide together.
And so it kind of loses that
feeling of connectivity, or
almost like this tactile feeling
that you're actually
moving a single surface.
And so what we decided to do
is actually flip the two.
And we moved the scrollable
tabs below that
fixed pane at the top.
We also tweaked the presentation
to, again, kind
of fall in with our
color scheme of
that brown and green.
And we also used basic text
contrast, like dark on accent
or white on accent to, again, I
guess, more prominently show
the visual hierarchy
of the information.
The most important thing on the
screen right now is the
current score--
2 to 1--
as well as ulterior elements,
such as the names of the
teams, as well as the
current time.
And then we took a look
at statistics.
How can we make statistics
look better in general?
Not much to say here.
We just, again, used the
same color scheme.
We simplified everything into
a single row of information.
You'll notice that on the left
you have a row indicating the
details, and then a row
for the progress bar--
not really the progress bar,
I guess the stats bar.
We simply integrated the two
into a single row, so that
it's much easier to scan.
So that was a doozy.
Nick, anything you
want to add here?
NICK BUTCHER: No, you summed
it up pretty nicely.
Yeah, I think the presentation
really works much better.
It's a lot more glanceable.
You can just kind of have a
glance at it and see which way
the game is going
by the stats.
As well, yeah, I completely
agree about connecting the
pager title script to the
actual view pager.
It felt quite disconnected
before on the before version
when you're moving the body of
the content, and there's a
stationary bit between you
and the tab strip moving.
It felt disconnected.
So it's a good change there.
ROMAN NURIK: Another thing I'll
mention is that in the
previous, or in the current
details for the game, like
what's the current game state,
you'll see that there's a
little notification icon.
It's not interactive, so
it's not really useful.
It's just an indicator saying
that, yes, you have
notifications turned on
for this game or not.
So we actually made that an
action bar icon, so that when
you touch that it toggles the
state of whether or not you
want notifications
for the game.
So let's move to the
next screen, which
is the tablet mock-up.
And Nick, do you want to
talk about this one?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So here we've really focused
on the in-game experience.
We figured that tablet is mostly
going to be used if you
sat at home, you're watching the
game already, and you're
wanting to have a second
screen experience.
So what we've tried to do here
is float up all the different
sections on the phone version,
or in a view pager type setup
onto a single, kind of
[? higher ?] single dashboard.
So as Roman pointed out, the
most important thing on the
screen is the current score,
what's going on.
So we've made that very, very
big and bold, and very clear,
exactly what's going on.
You can't really miss
the current score
on this screen here.
And the rest of the information,
we have this
horizontally scrollable.
So you can actually flick
around and see
what's going on.
Are some new videos
being posted?
How has the live
table changed?
I didn't quite finish
the line-up here.
But you can click in to see
some of the line-up, who's
playing in the roster.
So we've really tried to use the
extra real estate to kind
of make the information easier
to get at, and a bit more
playful and visual than the
phone view pager set-up, but
while retaining the most
important information on the
screen the whole time.
ROMAN NURIK: And I think that
the addition of the logos for
the teams is also another way
to use visual elements to
better hint at what's
going on.
So you could do even
more here.
You could do things like take
the team logos and use them in
the background, like
in a blurry state.
You could really make this
really immersive.
And I think this is
a great start.
This is a great way to start
showing all the different
pieces, almost like a game
dashboard all at once on a
tablet when you have
a larger screen.
All right, so in the interest of
time, let's move on to rich
notification.
And this is something that
Chris Banes put together.
And unfortunately, he
wasn't able to join,
which kind of sucks.
He should definitely
join next time.
But this is an example of
expanded notification.
Let's say you turn on
notifications for a specific
game and something happens.
And let's say you
then expand it.
So here's what it
can look like.
And this is using the
custom layout.
Again, you have different
options for each
notifications.
You can just show photo
or more text.
But you can also provide a
custom layout entirely.
And so this is an example of
what that can look like.
You still use the app icon, to
some degree, to indicate that
you're looking at the Live
Score Addicts app.
And so that's what that little
soccer ball icon means.
But you also show the most
important information first,
which is the current score,
as well as what
was the latest score.
In the 20th minute--
I'm going to butcher
his name-- is
it Popescu or Popeshu?
In the 20th minute, this guy
scored a goal, which is great
information to see as soon as
you expand that notification.
NICK BUTCHER: This is
a great start to it.
There's a lot of potential for
the rich notifications in
things like sports updates.
You want to have the information
quickly.
But if you can have that much
richer visual way of
delivering it, I think
users are going to be
delighted by that.
I think that's something they're
going to see and
really, really jump on about
your application.
So I think there's a lot of
stuff you could do here.
And we're playing around
with some ideas.
And we talked about maybe having
a freeze frame of the
goal or a celebration as the
[? picture ?] payload for the
rich notification.
There's a lot of things that
you could do with an
application here, which I'm
quite excited about.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, absolutely.
Any time you can use photos,
any time you have access to
photo content, showing it there,
or even a thumbnail
still from a video
is really useful.
And if you show a video, you
can even do something like
overlay a fake play icon to
indicate that this is a video.
So definitely use all
the content that you
have to your advantage.
And rich notifications,
it's really easy.
All you need to do is use
notification compat, provide
some intent, and you're set.
So there's no reason
not to do it.
Let's move on in the
interest of time.
So that was it for football apps
and Live Score Addicts.
Let's jump into Launcher
Icons.
And I think we're running a
little low on time, since we
had that little kerfuffle
in the beginning.
But we'll try to zoom
through this.
So Launcher Icons.
Basically the Android Design
Guide has a little bit about
icons in general.
So an icon is a graphic that
takes up a small portion of
screen real estate, provides a
quick intuitive representation
of an action, a status,
or your app.
So really in the space of 48 by
48 dips, you have to make
the best use of that space to
represent what your app does,
what it means.
And whether that's an icon
representing your brand, if
you have an existing service,
or if it's a utility app in
that space, try as best as
possible to represent what the
user will benefit from once
they use your app.
So one example is there was a
little side project that I
worked on that was
just basically a
single text box notepad.
And the icon was literally
just the text box.
It showed a little cursor, and
it showed the text box.
So you can do things
like that.
You don't necessarily have to
use this synecdoche to take
this very abstract idea and
compress it down into a single
little object.
But certainly that's
one possible way.
So let's look at some guidelines
on Launcher Icons.
Again, the actual asset size
is 48 by 48 dips In XHDPI,
that's 96 by 96.
For tablets, for Nexus 10
specifically, you should
provide an XXHDPI icon, and
that's 144 by 144 pixels.
Also, when you upload your app
to Google Play, it requests a
large app icon so that it can
show it in all its beautiful
glory on tablets and
phones and so on.
And that should be 512
by 512 pixels.
And generally what we've found
is you can probably start by
designing a 512 by 512.
I actually use 576 by 576,
for some reason.
But you can start with that,
and then slowly scale down.
It's generally a good idea to
start large and scale down,
rather than vice versa.
And then in terms of padding,
this is something that's
definitely changed over
the years for Android.
We used to request a fairly
large padding region.
But these days, you should
really just use either the
full image size, meaning no
padding, or if you have a
very, very square icon, then try
to use about three dips of
padding, give or take.
It's really up to you.
But in general, try to make it
fit in nicely with the rest of
the system icons, as well
as third party icons.
And those are generally going
to take up the full image
size, or have about one to
three dips of padding.
Before we move on and fly
through this, Nick, any other
comments on launchers?
NICK BUTCHER: No, you're
nailing it.
Go for it.
ROMAN NURIK: All right,
let's do it.
So a couple more guidelines.
Try to use a distinct
silhouette.
So don't just stick some
graphic inside of
a square or a circle.
That can work for now.
It can work as a default.
But try to really use a
distinct silhouette.
And we'll show good examples
of that in a bit.
Also, keep it simple
at the top.
Make sure that your icon, when
it's scaled down, it still
means something. it
still makes sense.
But at the very micro level,
feel free to add details, like
noise or subtle drop shadows,
and things like
that, as you see fit.
And then, very important,
don't try
to mimic other platforms.
So if you have an existing app
on Windows Phone, or an iPhone
iOS, don't just simply
copy over your icon.
It's OK to copy over the general
idea for the icon.
But make sure that it fits
well with the rest of the
system and fits in with
the guidelines.
Actually, before we look at
some examples, we recently
made changes to the guidelines
in the sense that it used to
be just facing forward.
You should make your icon
facing forward.
But now there's a slight
3D prospective.
And you'll see some
examples here.
There's just a few dips of
perspective that you see at
the very top.
And here's the rough kind of
camera angle you can use to
achieve that.
We don't have any numbers or
dimensions or anything.
But somebody asked
for the numbers.
This is the best we
could do for now.
But here's roughly what it
should look like if you're
doing this in a piece of
3D editing software.
And here's some not
good examples yet.
We're not there yet.
Some tools that can help you
with icon generation, there's
the Android asset studio, which
I'm sure many of you are
familiar with.
It could actually just generate
icons for you, just
to start with.
You should probably, when you're
ready to ship your
product, definitely hire a
designer and have them do a
custom icon for you that has a
distinct silhouette that is
very, very unique to your app.
That's going to really make it
pop when users are scanning
Google Play.
As well as the boiler plates
that are provided for free by
androidicons.com.
So they also give you circle
and square icons.
But using those basic shapes,
you can change it to whatever
silhouette you need.
The good thing about these is
that it actually has that
correct perspective and correct
styling, actually
correct example styling, that
you can use, as well as
different sizes.
They actually provide the 512
by 512, as well as all the
different smaller sizes that
are shown on the device.
And finally, here we're at a
few examples of icons that
follow our guidelines.
So Falcon Pro is an example.
And they show a slight
perspective above the kind of
futuristic bird-like creature.
Pageonce uses a very
basic circle.
But that's their app icon.
That's their branding.
It's very circular.
Pocket, which does something
interesting with the
prospective.
They actually show their
brand colors in the
depth of that square.
Expedia, which is one
of my favorites.
And this is, again, a very
distinct silhouette.
It's a briefcase, effectively.
But it shows their branding
really well.
And that briefcase, again, is
tilted at just the right
perspective.
We also have some good examples
from a Google I/O
app, which we've open-sourced,
as well as Solid Explorer,
which is a file explorer app.
And again, it's a folder
that's slightly open.
And has that very slight
perspective at the top.
All right, so I think that was
it for launcher icons.
NICK BUTCHER: I just--
And I think this is one of the
most important assets that you
put in your entire application,
users will judge
your application when you're
scanning a list of
applications in the Play store
on your icon, almost, alone.
So if you do, definitely work
with a designer, and make sure
they understand these guidelines
that we put out,
because this is such
an important asset.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, we probably
should have mentioned that at
the very beginning.
But if you have to
hire a designer
just to do your icon--
and a lot of designers are
actually just icon designers.
They don't do UI and
things like that--
it's definitely worth
the investment.
This is something that users
will see immediately.
If it stands out in the store
listening, in the search
results, if it stands out, then
that's going to be well
worth the conversions
that you get.
So moving on to Design News.
And again, we're
way over time.
But I think this is actually
pretty good for our scheduling
kerfuffle--
not a scheduling kerfuffle,
but the kerfuffle that
happened with our technology
in the beginning.
So for Design News we have
only a few things.
So speaking of Launcher Icons,
Michael Cook has actually
provided some PSDs of a
couple example icons.
And it's very similar to the
boiler plates, in the sense
that you can drop in your
stuff and tweak it in
Photoshop as you see fit.
And that's the link there.
You can download it, and I'm
guessing it's free of charge
and all that.
Next, we have--
NICK BUTCHER: Thank you,
Michael, yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: Yes, thank
you, Michael.
Next actually, I wanted to
highlight one of the designs
from the Google+ community, the
Android Design community.
So Rajesh Handa, sorry if I
mispronounced your name.
But Rajesh actually has been
posting a whole bunch of
different examples,
design concepts,
to the Google+ community.
And I think some of them
are really wonderful.
This specific one has a really
unique color palette.
And I think it's just
really well done.
The information that you're
currently looking at, the most
important information, the unit
conversion, converting
between kilometers and meters,
for example, that pops
immediately.
Nothing else has as much
contrast as that.
And I think that's just one of
the better designs we've seen
from the community.
And also, there's a little drag
handle on the left, so
you could switch between
converting from kilometers to
meters very easily.
And I think the last piece of
Design News is we talk a lot
about apps on the show.
But we don't really
talk about games.
And that's because usually games
have their own very,
very custom bespoke UI.
And this is an example of a
puzzle game that uses lots and
lots of hollow elements.
And it even uses the hollow
color palette in a really
successful way.
So I just wanted to point out
that if you're building a
game, especially a puzzle game
or a brain teaser, things like
that, you don't have to have
your own custom UI.
You can definitely succeed
still with hollow.
So I just wanted to point that
out and put it out there for
you all to check out.
Anything else that we missed,
Nick, before we sign off?
NICK BUTCHER: No, no, I think
that's covered it.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So thanks again for joining.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And bye from
me, Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And we will see you
hopefully next week, where
Adam will join us once again.
Adam actually couldn't make
it today, because of
some stuff at home.
Oh, wait, he's on vacation.
That's right.
But yes, so hopefully we'll
join in next week.
As always, see you next time on
Android Design in Action.
NICK BUTCHER: And remember to
tune in to the App Clinic this
Friday, as well, to see what
those guys do with some of
these football score
apps as well.
ROMAN NURIK: That's right.
See you all, thanks
for joining.
[MUSIC PLAYING]